here in LA there are tons of food
options and it's hard to know which ones
are the best so today I'm bringing two
of my friends to show me their favorite
spots in the city
this is tastiest and we're trying to
find the tastiest taco in LA let's go
let's go cut one though I hope you have
insurance here we go where we going
first so Nikki I don't know exactly what
kind of tacos you like but this is a
really unique taco there are endless
possibilities with tacos right there's
ways to do it really really simply
there's ways to do it at home and then
you can also like dish out a lot of
money for a really elevated type of taco
and I'm open to all possibilities I love
everything about tacos so I'm going to
take you to my favorite taco place it's
called fiesta curry at downtown tasty
taco I've ever had is the chorizo taco
it's got this layer of crispy but gooey
cheese on the tortilla this juicy
chorizo and potatoes it's just got so
much flavor and so much Flair that I
really think you're gonna enjoy it you
too ray I want to change your mind
change my I'm gonna change right
I'm ray Garces chef/owner of broken
Spanish and BS taqueria here in downtown
Los Angeles and today I'm going to show
you how to make our chorizo and potato
taco so bas taqueria is sort of my
interpretation of a contemporary
taqueria one thing that was exciting for
me was there's kind of an opportunity to
revisit some of my favorites either you
know growing up or in my adult life that
I eat but a chance to put my own spin on
it you know introduce my own preferences
into it and be as taqueria I think what
makes us really special is it a really
the attention to not only to detail but
to ingredient into sourcing so we grind
all of our masa fresh leaves and
heirloom
Tripti I was sustainable oh no deuce
sustainably raised all of those like
really impact yeah but the flavor I
think it really kind of takes it to a
next level let's make some tacos let's
do it you ready yes okay well we have to
start with the tortilla so we ran we
press our own fresh air so you can help
me with that
yes so this is the this is the masa we
actually grind our own masa it's just
corn that's cooking then ground binded
daily it's blue it's blue huh
so it's a blue corn we give it a little
fresh okay so you peel it back and
you're gonna put it throw it on that
side of your hand and then start it back
in the hand you don't set it down don't
learn about Nikki all right okay like
this smash so far so good
can't really can't mess that one I know
it has a tear that's fine yeah we'll
just put it down I'll show you
[Music]
then we have a it's a sort of a to
cheese blend and we have a cassava haha
which is a walk in cow's milk cheese and
then we have a little bit of jack cheese
in there for melting melting some cheese
melt with some cheese but right on the
surface
oh man that smells good okay now this is
the fun part so we have these really
cool tools underneath that's why we're
here okay now that's mine let's see
yours okay all right great
it's looking pretty perfect right now
okay go for it now oh now you're gonna
get ready for the scoop things you're
gonna have your hand gear got and then
onto your hand all in all in
we're not done yet no no no so these are
just potatoes that we've roasted off
you're given a little bit of a smashing
so those are gonna fry until they're
done at about 375 so you know they're
done when they get like a nice kind of
dark golden brown on the outside we can
sort of err on the side of slightly you
know overcook because you want more of
that crispy
well yeah cuz the next part is gonna be
the moisture and so we're just going to
take a little bit of this chorizo so we
have this a little salsa here you can
take some of these potato pieces okay so
we have some cotija oh yeah I'll let you
give it a shot well see the other good
side technique yeah I can get cheese on
the spoon so this guy's is my favorite
taco in Los Angeles so what are we
drinking this is the cocoa bang have a
bite of the taco wash it down with your
cocoa bang you've had perfect yeah
orange it's like an orange pina colada
feel like I'm on a beach in Mexico that
orange is for taco okay I'm actually
just gonna dig in cuz I got a darling
[Music]
we are good
I can never had this kind of typo before
yeah I taco homie eats like Tokyo it's
like me in cabbage slaw but too much
time also I've never had cheese and me
and potatoes yeah the tacos very
interesting combination each component
of the target was so well thought out
we have been so purposeful and it comes
together really really nicely this
chance takes it over the top though oh
my god you really can't look cute when
you eat a taco but like with this top go
I don't care there's something I knew
look do I
Oh honestly I might have to unbutton my
pants on this one
I'm follow that was a big taco next time
we have reaiized taco sorry eh where are
we going
so we are going to payday cash it's West
Hollywood so we are trying their octopus
taco whoa so this taco had everything
you hoped for in Bangkok oh it's salty
and also it's char grill it has like
smokiness and also they put avocado so
you have creaminess it has pickled
onions
so it had tangy sour kick to it
flavors yeah I'm definitely interested
its flavor bomb also octopus in Japanese
it's taco oh it's gonna be taco taco my
name is Walter Manske I'm the chef/owner
of petty-cash taqueria today I'm gonna
show you how to make the grilled octopus
taco Betty cash is inspired by all the
grey people from Mexico that I've worked
with over the past 30 years in the
kitchen who've shared their culture
their great food with me
and this is a tribute to all of them the
octopus taco is actually one of the few
tacos on the menu that's actually not
even mine
I put it together with a friend from
Tijuana
oh so as a taqueria down there he came
up here in the beginning and helped me
out with a bunch of recipes and we put
that one together right here we're
making the tortillas can I get in here
can I get it a little bit of this action
that's right not too much farther sue
you guys this looks familiar
oh there's already one in there for you
just there that one on I am
yeah look at that so first we cook the
octopus and red wine Oh some onions some
celery some spices
that cooks for 45 minutes and then right
what part of the octopus do you eat the
legs are the best part we make the talk
about of the legs is there a type of
octopus that you used to cook with
weren't there different types of octopus
these come from Spain and we'll have to
play can I cut one yeah all right so
just go oh that's why me Wow how I'm
just curious
okay you got a leg what's next this is
uh almost like a pesto so why is it a
good flavor yeah he's an octopus a
little garlic get it nice and crispy
around oh man that smells good it's
already cooked
it's already acted me
whoa looks good right that looks great
cheese oh oh yeah pop a couple tortillas
on top of that now we're gonna take our
octopus oh we are gonna top it up Wow
then we got cheese a little bit of
octopus we're gonna put a piece of
avocado pickled on yes
what is that this is chard chili to our
Bros and some roasted peanuts we'll put
a touch with cilantro on there there it
is yeah we go what are we drinking
grapefruit margarita oh that's not I'm
doing a horchata you can drive home for
me Cheers you know it's not cocoa bang
yep I like it this is a really tasty
there's so much in here you know okay
here we go whoa there's so many flavors
I don't know what's happening oh and
there's a kick at the end oh wow that
sauce that peanut sauce yeah what is
what is it so Panthers very tender it's
a very tender little hint of the pesto
yeah and there's good there's good
acidity to read on the edge and then the
avocado kind of cools everything down
yeah I love the peanuts what a weird
I know I know different eyes but they're
really good you know what I don't even
really like seafood all that much but
the fact that oh I would come back and I
would order this octopus taco is really
saying something
this is a crazy taco yeah hey so today
has been a taco full day thank you both
for taking me your favorite spot the
octopus taco was so complex just out of
this world and the Theresa Pappas taco
was like all of these really wonderful
familiar taco flavors which is like an
elevated fashion but I do think one
edges out the other for me just by like
this much I think I have to go with
treason republic
I knew I liked yeah I like I was so
shocked at how good it was but I love
the taco taco it's crazy I just want to
introduce everyone to that talk--i cuz
it's so out of there this a histogram
you start tasting like salty and both of
my peers yeah you're slow go go go go
[Music]